the goal would always be to take care of
yourself and try to
just do what grandma used to do chicken
soup sleep
vitamins yeah whatever it takes
whiskey and lemon or hot top have a hot
toddy
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
the topic of food
health and wellness is uh definitely a
favorite of mine
and today's guest kelly levesque is a
pro at that
she's a holistic nutritionist and a
celebrity health coach
her clients are oh you know people like
jessica alba jennifer garner emmy rossum
you know these very beautiful healthy
perfect looking people
well she tells them what to eat and how
to take care of themselves and from the
inside out that makes them look good on
the outside too she's
amazing woman she's she's super positive
and i think that's what you'll come to
in the end is realizing just how
her positivity has really carried her
through her life she
she actually started out in the medical
field and then
being a nutritionalist to people and
helping them with something she did as a
side hustle
and eventually just got to the point
where she could do it as a full-time job
so let this be an inspiration to all of
you out there
that you can have a side hustle while
you're doing your real job and
eventually make it your full-time job
so please enjoy the show from this very
inspirational woman
i love health and fitness and wellness
and food and all that stuff
and it really seems like you have too
like looking at
you know what you went to school for the
jobs you've had it's
all in that same vein so do you remember
maybe your first maybe you didn't even
identify
with it then but can you look back now
and go oh yeah
of course because i've always been into
wellness
i mean i can go all the way back to
freshman year of high school
i remember loving health it was my first
science course
i remember acing every test and
easily remembering what was in the book
and
but the weird part was is when i was in
high school and then applying to college
becoming a registered dietitian and
becoming
a doctor really wasn't top of mind for
me um
i'm the oldest of three girls and i
really wanted to make my dad proud and
he was a business
finance guy so i sort of
really just was impressionable and
wanted to make him proud
and like 27 relatives that went to usc
so i had
my eyes set on usc and to be a trojan
but
it was then again my like junior year
going into my senior year
at sc and i took all of my science
courses that senior year
called my dad in tears i was like what
am i doing
nature of human health and disease was
the best grade i
ever got in a college class and
i was like i should be an md i should be
a registered dietitian
i should go back for kinesiology this
has all been a waste
finance statistics it's like what am i
doing
why didn't you do that um so at the time
my dad being an entrepreneur um was
willing to support each of myself and my
sisters through college which
was such a blessing to not have student
loans but we knew the day we graduated
we were cut off
so going into my senior year he's like
well if you want to take on some
debt and go back to school for another
year and a half at usc or extend your
day you're more than welcome to do that
but you could always look into
how could you have a career in the space
talk about biology talk about nutrition
talk about health
without being an md
and so i ended up
getting you know going down the path and
getting a concentration in nature of
human health and disease
and i worked for pharmaceutical company
right out of school johnson and johnson
you've probably heard of it
it's my first job it was like love and
other drugs it was
if you ever saw that i
you're a glorified caterer really yeah
but
the i mean the interesting part of the
job was being able to read studies
and relay that information to doctors
and
try to help them understand how
the drug was going to affect their
patient what kind of drugs were you
what kind of drugs are you pushing so
proton pump inhibitor which
is called ass effects it basically is
like a nexium or prilosec it shuts down
proton pumps which are these little
pumps in your stomach that give off acid
right so it's up for acid reflux and i
sold levofloxacin which is a really
intense antibiotic
and knowing what i know now and knowing
what i knew
at the time it was like
it was like angel and a devil on your
shoulder like i knew
taking an antibiotic was blowing out and
obliterating
gut microbiomes and that you know but at
the same time
it's killing these bacterial infections
that
put people in the hospital and can be
life-threatening but people use
antibiotics so frivolously they're just
like
you know popping them like skittles oh
you don't feel so great here's a z pack
here's this
how many i mean like how many days a
year can you use an antibiotic
and be like you know what i wouldn't
worry about that
i would say once a year would be my max
album
yeah but like the goal would be to not
ever have to
to take an antibiotic and a lot of times
people are being treated with
antibiotics when it's a viral infection
which means that you're
you know obliterating your gut
microbiome and this
is amazing ecosystem in your body that
produces short-chain fatty acids for
brain health
and you know i like to say that
you know keeps your digestion going but
it's you know the dry weight of your
stool is so much dead bacteria too and
i mean genetic pathways and all kinds of
things are affected by these
short chain fats that are produced by
your bacteria so if you're
getting rid of all this bacteria you're
getting rid of that layer that protects
you from the outside world
and you're affecting your immune system
for the future so the goal would always
be
to take care of yourself and try to just
do what grandma used to do
chicken soup sleep vitamins
yeah whatever it takes whiskey and lemon
or
hot top have a hot toddy yeah i know you
probably know about that from the south
yeah so it's you know i didn't last very
long in that job i moved into
a cancer role in actually devices
it was a radiation device that was
implanted
so it was instead of being radiating the
whole body for breast cancer we were
waiting in a very small
area but the goal with that was to move
into a role
where i could work in cancer and then
eventually move into genetics
so i had this really long career um you
know six of the eight years that i
was working in the medical field i was
in cancer and genetics
which i really loved and that's gonna
say does it did it feel fulfilling
because it does kind of
fill that you know md side of it the
nerd in me
loved it like getting into the studies
and seeing
um stuff coming so the last company that
i worked for was
through the nether it was a subsidiary
of the netherlands cancer institute the
netherlands cancer institute
and um and what was so cool
was in the netherlands they have all of
these solid-state tumors
and they've never been treated so they
weren't treated with chemotherapy before
they were removed from the body so what
they were able to do is run
the genome of these tumors and then you
can find out
well what are the feeding pathways of
these tumors and what genes
are basically turned up or turned down
and so that was really fun because
when you go to talk to an oncologist and
i had the eight west coast states and
the very
at the very end before i moved into my
own practice
they wanted to know what i had to say
they wanted to know the information
they wanted to know how it's applicable
with their patients which
it was changing the game what it used to
do is just take a bunch of chemotherapy
and throw it at someone cross their
fingers and hope
it you know was toxic enough to kill
everything and now kind of like
antibiotics just it's killing everything
just not you yeah antibiotics are
killing the bacteria but with cancer
right like they basically get to the
point of killing everything but you
exactly and they're really breaking down
your body and there are so many side
effects to all of it and so
the cool part with it was understanding
that like one specific chemotherapy
agent was going to be really efficacious
because of its genetic make you know
your tumors genetic makeup
instead of throwing the kitchen sink
they were really targeted and it was
personalized medicine based on genetics
and
that is you know that just that's so
fascinating i'm i'm very
into like i mean i've had my blood
tested a couple of times for
food intolerances and you know those
food sensitivity tests
they're more common now but the first
time i did it was like 2013 i think the
beginning of 13. so
they weren't really popular then you
actually had to seek out like a doctor
that did them and sent the tests off now
you can
they get go straight to the lab um but i
love that stuff
and so is there i mean there's probably
so much that you can find out about
somebody
through lab work and absolutely i mean
like
nowadays in my own practice so i
transitioned i sort of moonlit
this nutrition um business my bulb
yeah tell me about initially like how so
it started off i mean like you called it
your side hustle which is totally true i
had so many side hustles and i was still
working
um so what was what that looked like for
you initially like what was the part
what was the thing you were dabbling in
that you didn't think anything about
necessarily
well so every single time i went into
pubmed research for my cancer genetics
job
i would find myself kind of um
you know down a rabbit hole about lipid
metabolism
or insulin resistance or metabolic
syndrome
or you know chromosomes yeah i go down
those rabbit holes all the time
of course lipid resistance that's the
one
you know i just the these kind of th
those facets of health were really
interesting to me and it wasn't that i
had to read
which i love well and good and mind body
green and those
you know health websites that give a lot
of information i write articles for them
i have courses with them
but for me going into the research was
really really fun
and then i was just that annoying girl
at parties who was like oh tell me about
you know your bowel movements and your
skin
and like i i would geek out like if you
told me that you had food intolerances
or
i would want to know what test you took
and what you were intolerant to
and how it made you feel when you cut it
out how did you feel
and so i want to know yeah yeah i do
no we don't have to go into it but i'm
happy to talk about it because i love
that stuff but
but so that was what you saw you started
so you started you were doing like side
side like you were just kind of being
distracted a little bit by
or no you weren't distracted you were
just learning even more yeah i was
i yeah i was marinating in the
information yeah
really excited by it and my
one of my best friends i had sort of
pushed her out to start her own business
in events
because she had really worked on these
amazing events here in l.a like hell
women in hollywood
us weekly parties like all this really
cool stuff i'm like you are the vision
like why don't you just go out and do it
on your own
pushed her pusher pusher and she did it
and then she turned the tables on me and
was like
so you need to stop talking to people at
parties about their health and just go
help people
so i started i went back to school and
then
for nutrition i started it as a side
hustle i started sharing on instagram
knowing that you were going to
transition or did you go back to school
for your side hustle just
because you were that curious and you
wanted that information
or were you preparing for the transition
i was preparing for the transition
i by the time i finally did it i had
you had your job going on and you were
doing this other stuff i think that's
important for people to know because
there are so many people that when you
tell them like oh i can't do that i have
a job it's like
and whether you think you can or you
think you can't you're right yeah so if
you say i can't i can't i can't that is
your reality
and you just didn't let that be your
reality you were like look i'm working
i'm doing this job it's like
supe very difficult and intellectual and
scientific and it
stimulates me somewhat but this other
thing that i really want to do
and so you just filled your plate up a
little more full but yeah
you got to still makes take steps to
move forward and
while it wasn't your full-time job and
you weren't doing you know consultations
and actually helping people one-on-one
and
writing books and all the things that
you've done now you
you were starting the process i think
it's important for people to understand
you can start a process
until you feel confident enough that
it's something that it's still going to
be a leap of course it's going to be a
leap
sure but you're you're going to at least
have some kind of foundation
and it's funny that you say that because
i side hustled bull by kelly for three
years
and i went to school for a year a little
over a year
and i started seeing clients and i saw
clients for almost two full
full years what on at nights um at lunch
breaks on weekends
like i was the girl in scrubs at cedar
sinai
talking to an oncologist i would walk
across the street to the coffee bean
change into a blazer and jeans no meet
someone like for an hour at my lunch
change in that bathroom and walk back
across the street you're an inspiration
so
i'm seriously it's like you have to want
it you have to you want if a side hustle
needs to
you need to want that to become your
main hustle and
i think looking back i could have
probably left my um
cancer and genetics job maybe a year
prior
um but you know i jumped off a curb
instead of a cliff
yeah and i knew that my phone was
ringing at the time
and when the time came to really leave
that job
um you know i was giving up a lot of
stability a 401k
a company car insurance salary insurance
and you i wouldn't have to hire and fire
being at your job
probably too much yeah so it had to work
and i had
i was so hungry when that time happened
so it was only a couple months before i
was flying to new york and pitching
literary agents because i was like i
need
to get this information out there this
needs to be
something that is sustainable i can't
i can't you can't go from being a
salaried employee and managing people
and taking
care of like a big part of the united
states for your role
to being an hourly employee right you
need something else
you need you need to diversify to have
stability
and so i wanted to help more people and
i needed that
bigger versification reach and i
actually just listened to a podcast the
other day i think it was bob proctor
with lewis house who we just saw on the
way out
yeah um and um he was saying that
wealthy people don't have one source of
income
no and actually my the dean at usc
told us that most millionaires in la
have over five sources of income
at any given time and that could be
under one business or umbrella
but you always should be looking to
diversify and have like
passive forms of income whether that's
an investment property
product speaking engagements one-on-one
with your clients and so i started to
think about like
how can i really elevate my brand
and help people at the same time in
different segments of the market
so book came to you right away yeah
the the the the nerd or the geek that
you call yourself i don't call you that
yeah um i'm proud of that that's okay
that's
there's nothing to be ashamed of i mean
that's that's like deep into the
intellectual topics that um
help a lot of people um so a book came
to mind right away then
well i haven't read so many books right
over the years
what's been your favorite health book oh
it like it really changes based on the
year but i think um
easy reader let's think about an easy
reader for me
i really do think grain brain by dr
perlmutter for a scientific book is a
great
look at how how gluten affects the body
and the brain and redirects blood flow
and and you know what is healthiest for
our bodies right
i think he's done a really good job and
the updated version is really good
um but it depends on what you're looking
for
you know and for me what i found was i
could go out and read
one of those diet books that was written
by an md in a weekend
like it was an easy read for me i'd
highlight a couple things act like it
was a textbook
sort of reference the study look at the
studies they were referencing see if
they made sense to me
but what i didn't find is that between
those and like the pinterest
soup cleanse diet that people look up to
lose 10 pounds
you know before a vacation there was
nothing in the middle
that trusted people with the science and
gave them a little bit of light
structure to eat what they wanted to eat
everything i everything in that space
was sort of like
along the lines of um you know
really like allowing people to trust
their intuit intuitive eating
right well for me intuitive eating if i
have a donut my intuitive next meal is a
piece of pizza
like and i know on a biological level
that's called emotional eating
yeah it's because my blood sugar is
going up and crashing down and all i'm
craving is more carbohydrates and
starches and it's those highly palatable
foods that are
they're like drugs they're our first
drugs growing up you know
for kids you see it they go to a
sleepover they come home they're crazed
and i remember feeling that way so i
wanted people to have
that light science but a little bit of
structure so they understood how to
balance their blood sugar how to eat an
anti-inflammatory diet
you know how to shut down hunger
hormones instead of fighting not to
eat right if it's the craving that
you're failing from
stop the craving exactly and there's so
much so many people out there that are
just trying to white knuckle
willpower their way from meal to meal or
they read one of these diet books that
inspires them for a minute they take
that pdf of like what they can eat and
what they can't eat
or they're doing something that is
unsustainable like the ketogenic diet
i talked about in 2014 in an article for
birdie which is like a click media it's
like a website for
uh beauty and health and no one was
talking about it but it was in the
research it was coming out in the
studies and i was seeing it
but it's not something that i think
people can sustain until they're 90
years old
right it's something that you could use
as a functional
intervention to get sugar cravings to
increase brain health to burn some fat
and feel good
some kind of a reset yeah but it but you
have to look at it that way
and the thing is is people jump into
these things thinking that they're going
to do it for the rest of their life
and then they fail and their confidence
you know hits the ground and they feel
bad about themselves because they can't
you know control what's on their fork
sure instead of thinking about
their business and what they can give
back to the world and their family and
all those really all the things that
really make life worth living
so i tried to really answer what i saw
was like a big black hole in the
marketplace which is like
how do i give you the tools to eat what
you love
to understand a little bit of the
science to stay motivated because we're
motivated by information
and then really you know be able to live
a flexible
life right so that's what i tried to do
with the book or just or okay and with
my business yeah
my clients yeah like it isn't something
where i you know i do consultations i
sit down with people we have roles i
mean
there are people with very strict rules
and they have to be in some type of like
x-men suit or whatever yeah and we have
to get serious
but when it comes to you know
finishing those deadlines it really is
about integrating it into a lifestyle so
that
they're confident eating clean going to
dinner with yeah friends
needs to not be a diet it needs to be a
lifestyle it needs to be something that
is not temporary but
permanent absolutely and the permanence
can evolve but the permanence of taking
care of yourself and eating responsibly
drinking responsibly having the
emotional attachment to food
with a with a level of understanding
that's one thing that i feel like
you know people think of healthy eating
and they think it's a punishment i'm
like
you're ridiculous you obviously have no
idea how
um you don't realize but i made you
basically a vegan paleo uh dinner
tonight
and you didn't even know it you know you
had no idea that was gluten-free you had
no idea that was dairy free you had no
idea
right but so so many people don't don't
cook for themselves or they don't know
what's healthier they just have this
negative association
with food and fitness like being
punishments and i just think that that
emotional
connection or disconnection is so
detrimental to people because
it's somehow not a positive well and i
think a lot of times
when people they they have to have the
payoff you have to have the reward and
so
for someone like you who is and you know
you have this amazing athletic career
and you're taking really good care of
yourself and you're working out and
you're eating clean and you're feeling
good
you know what that feels like at the
other end of that i think for a lot of
people they get into something that
isn't sustainable
they think that it means deprivation it
feels like deprivation
they never get the payoff and so they're
not motivated by
like the outcome yeah and what i mean i
grew up playing soccer i remember what
it felt like to play a tournament the
whole entire weekend
sunday night you know be back at my
parents house and feel
sort of like a golden retriever that
went for a run i'm like i feel so good i
feel so relaxed like
all those happy endorphins i would
always sleep so well
like that's such a good feeling and i
want people to have to know what that
feels like yeah i mean that was
my goal with um i had a book come out
the beginning of last year
called pretty intense and it's mind
food and body so with the the the the
what i had hoped with
with writing the book and people doing
the 90-day program
was that one 90 days was lo 90 days was
long enough to
to prove to you how good you can feel
and so many people so when i did the
trial group for the for the workout
program
the the diet was you know recommended as
well
and there were so many people along the
way and i had i had an open forum for it
so i could talk to people about how it
was going so i really wanted the
information
um they would be four to six weeks in
and they'd be like
i had pizza and i felt so bad i don't
even want to do that anymore and i was
like
thank you that's the answer you want you
want people to realize that
i feel i'm working out so to feel good
right
because i know that when i don't eat
dairy and when i don't eat gluten my
energy levels are through the roof
all the time i know that when i work out
i feel more confident and i can
accomplish even more things in my life
i wanted that to be what happens which
sounds similar right
yes you want people to have it be a
lifestyle and when they pull back like
that and they have that pizza it's not
that p
you can never have a piece of pizza but
right when you're constantly
eating pizza thursday friday saturday
night you don't know what a food like
that food hangover feels like what that
brain fog feels like you are
you are in that live it and that's like
your normal yeah so elevating everyone
so that they know what it feels like
then they're making those healthier
choices they're like oh i can get this
cauliflower crust pizza
in or i can make it and i can still get
those italian flavors without that
you know brain fog the next day like
compromising texture
yeah slight compromise and texture to
feel amazing that was my biggest that
was the biggest thing for me in my
like diet history was when i cut out
dairy and gluten after doing a food
sensitivity test
then i because it was everything i ate
was in it and i was like what the hell
am i gonna do
um but i had so much more energy it was
like i never had
i never i never was not motivated i was
like oh
it's three i go work out again i guess
you know i was like oh i'll go for a
walk i'll do something
i've got a double day yeah i do two days
all the time that's where it started i
actually started with
i had done ivf to freeze my eggs and i
gained like four or five pounds out of
nowhere in two weeks just hormones or
injections yeah horrible and so i was
like wow i
i guess i'm gonna have to lose the
weight for real this is real fat
yeah fun oh fun it didn't go back to
normal like they said after
one cycle um and so i decided to do
paleo from just dairy and gluten free
and
then i started doing some two-a-days
that's great
yeah and it all worked together because
i had plenty energy for the two a days
because i was even more restricted with
my diet after
cutting out the grains and beans and all
the little extra bits
cutting the corners but yeah two days
there's energy for that too
yeah so what was the point that you
finally made the transition from um
side hustle and you know basically
spending 20 18 hours of
every day working uh yeah so i started
bewell by bl by kelly in september of
2012
and that was after going to school and i
took it full time in september of 2015.
so what happened like was there like
something that happened um
is there a job that you got or like a
client that you got in true kelly
fashion
a gradual curve works for me so i had
told
my boss at the cancer genetics job i was
like look
she already knew that i had this side
hustle we had a really good relationship
i had like
actually helped her with her food at one
of our conferences so we were out at a
weekend so she looked at you and goes
girl this is so your call
yeah like you have to do it um and she's
like but you manage a few of our really
big accounts
like cedar sinai here in l.a was like
one of these accounts where i had great
relationships i had been working with
them for so long
she's like why don't we see if we can
get you a consulting gig for just the
summer
until september 1st or 15th or something
like that ended up where
it was just a really soft landing and i
knew that they was coming
because when i had gone to quit she
asked me to stay on to consult for three
months
and still a great story because people
when you're honest about what you love
it resonates with people
they can't help but be happy for you so
she sounds like she was so happy for you
but yet
you know you're valuable so you've got
to transition easy it doesn't have to be
like a death it doesn't have to be like
i quit today and now i have nothing and
now i start from nothing
it can be it can it can not only be a
transition but then it can actually be
like you just said a soft landing that's
wonderful
it's it's interesting because i mentor
younger
holistic nutritionists and health
coaches and so many of them
just hate the job they're in so much
that they just wanna
they wanna absolutely like quit the next
day and they're gonna start this big
massive business but i think the hard
part
with that is the beginning of any
business is such a hustle and it's such
a grind
and not only do you really want it but
what i didn't have to do
was sort of be like a used car salesman
i didn't have to tell my clients
oh well you need to sign up for 15
sessions with me
i got to prove it every single session
it was like oh yeah we'll just do
one-on-one consultations i have an
hourly rate
if it works for you if it resonates for
you if you find it beneficial we can
meet again you weren't desperate i
wasn't desperate
and that's really important too because
you really have to show your worth it
can't be about the money you can't seem
you know really you really just need to
bring value and that allowed me to do
that
and it's something that i i really
always coach these young girls
and um i don't have a guy that i'm
coaching but all these young women
um to really start to to build their
side hustle to see people on the weekend
if you really want it
you have to give up your personal time
to do it yeah so you should kind of be
happy to do it on some level
it's so and if you're not then you're
probably not you probably didn't find
your true side hustle or your
passion right because you were willing
so at the same time what i found was
ironic and reading up on you was that
your husband
also ditched his main job for his side
hustle at the same time
hello yeah yeah i think there was a
really
entrepreneurial uh energy going on
in our house at the time um i just was
so excited to be honest like
like i said um the first half a dozen
clients i worked with i actually worked
with for free
for testimonials one of them was one of
our really good friends getting ready
for her wedding i was up at 5am with her
i was working out with her to keep her
motivated i was shopping with her
i was like sending her recipes holding
her hands yeah
i don't do that with clients now you
have to want it and i am here to give
you the scientific information about the
nutrition and that's about it
um but it was really like i was in it
and i was so excited and my husband
chris was an attorney he was a corporate
attorney for seven years and we'd been
married for like six months and he came
home
like uh yeah so i don't think i want to
do this anymore and i was like okay
wow what do you want to be when you're
what was that conversation like do you i
mean like was there
did you test the relationship or was
this a was it all positive i mean
i think if it was i think if it was any
of the other guys i had dated before my
husband
i i would have worried that they would
be watching the nfl network
on the couch when i was like out working
golf all day
thursday friday saturday sunday exactly
um but chris is super driven
he you know i like i am like his i
brag about him like i'm his mom i'm like
he was valedictorian of his high school
he had like you know scholarships to
ucla got into lost you know
he he'd proven it to me that he's like
such a hard driven worker and
i wanted him to be passionate and love
like what he was doing i'm
always optimistic always glass half full
and um yeah so i was like you can have a
year paid and like i'll pay the law
school loans
and um and that's another reason why my
side hustle took a little bit longer to
take full time
because he actually started he quit
being an attorney
to write screenplays before i took my
job full time
um wow yeah it's crazy and then you know
fast forward hey uh babe you couldn't
have maybe written that screenplay while
you were still working
making 5.90 an hour yeah yeah the
problem with that type of career is it
was
14 16 hour days uh many nights i was
like
making dinner for us and then driving it
to his law firm well the problem with
law is of course there's always more
work you could be doing
totally so yeah yeah so you don't just
go home you're like
it's just eternal yeah it was it wasn't
his hours were not as flexible and we
both recognized that
so um yeah yeah poor guy he got sucked
back into bull by kelly looking at all
my contracts and
um okay that's being a supportive
husband yeah
using all the benefits i'm sure you made
him healthy meals didn't you yeah yeah
no he eats pretty well i mean he trolls
me on the internet
his instagram is at be bad by chris so
he likes he likes his fair share of
pizza and beer and all that but
yeah yeah how um how is your guys's
relationship do you
like to do all the same things um i
would say we're both pretty passionate
about travel and being active
he grew up surfing and playing soccer i
grew up really snowboarding and playing
soccer but surfed a little and he skied
a little
so we've had a lot of overlaps we really
enjoy being active together
um he uh you know i give him a hard time
it's funny his instagram has gone dark
he actually eats a lot cleaner than he
gives off like he makes himself a fab
four smoothie every morning
and he's always asking me about the
benefits of the meals we're eating he's
a really good student
but i think it keeps him motivated too
um but we have our fair share of like
issues like any couple like
he really got sucked into my business
like he was copy editing my books
and um yeah and in conversation with my
manager and my
editors and he had his own b1 by kelly
email and then we
you know we finished the second book and
finished up a couple of contracts for
this year
and he retired again from b-wall by
kelly's like we need to unravel this and
keep our
personal life separate from the work
life because you want to keep that
sexual energy and you want to come
together at the end of the day and say
like
yeah what did you do today not like
should we talk about that deal
yeah because that's that's going to
really like chill the energy i mean
that brings me to a thought of balance
and you know my theory on balance is
that it's not
real period like not you can't in one
moment be balanced
right now you're here and you know right
now he might be at work and so
clearly it's out of balance right now so
it just ebbs and flows and so
sometimes you need help sometimes he
needs help sometimes you come together
in a much more
you know um symbiotic you know
loving passionate way and other times
it's like look i
i need you to check and make sure this
is okay because you know i gotta sign
this contract and i trust you more than
anyone in the world and i'm
sorry but um how how is that balance
um between that and and having a son now
yeah you know um so our son sebastian is
almost 10 months old and
he we call him the gummy bear because he
like really doesn't have any teeth yet
and he smiles
the kid needs dentures or something it's
pretty funny but he'll get those teeth
soon enough yeah you'll know when he
starts crying all the time and
slobbering right
yeah it's just like drool a drool beard
um
he's really brought a lot of energy to
our lives and a lot of magic
and we are we are seeing life and
slowing down we're seeing life in a
totally different light and we have
completely different perspective on
what's
important um but it also really makes
you efficient at your job
because you have to trade off the time
of like
well if i go do this is it important
enough to take away
time from sebastian we call him bash
bash man
it is it his time or is this really
important enough for me to
or should i be prioritizing this other
thing so
it makes you really good at saying no
and um
because you respect yourself and your
family not i used to be
like the the yes woman i went to every
event i supported everyone
i wanted to learn and grow and be there
and
when you add an element of a family
member to your life
you really are
you're you can run yourself ragged and
that's not healthy there and so my
health is and taking care of myself so i
can take care of my family
and then support my community is really
my priority buckets
so um and sebastian had a hard time
coming into the world like he was
he went to chla for two weeks children's
hospital of los angeles and he's 100
healthy killed right now
uh but it was really scary in the
beginning and we had to
we you know really just total priority
shift but
it's actually made being a mom super
easy and changed
my perspective there where people worry
like when their kids gonna take their
first steps
and what milestones they're reaching and
i'm like i have a healthy child
and he's loving life get some
perspective pretty quickly yeah
so it's been amazing what is your um
personal
sort of health like whether i i'm
curious like
what your normal day of food is and then
maybe like what your fitness is
yeah um so we'll start with food because
yeah that's my happy place
me too um that's why i like for me i
can't do intermittent fasting i can't
like i'm like not one of those people
that wants to food prep i'm like no i
want to cook
yeah and you just make like a ten of
these things and 10 of these things
and four pounds of that i'm like no i i
want to eat what i want then and i'll
make it fit the macros that
feel good and the calories yeah and i'm
a lot like you actually so
um i talk about it in my book but i
created
a light structure plan to help people
balance their blood sugar
and eat to satiety and it's called the
fab four so i'm looking for four things
at every meal protein fat
fiber and something green leafy greens
herbs
i'm looking for that color the reason
for that is
like the essential amino acids from
protein you have to get that from your
food
protein sources what can they be um well
it depends on what you like to eat so
for me
i am a red meat eating woman so
that can be bison lamb steak it can be
poultry chicken turkey
any type of fish shellfish what about
the quality of
like um you know vegan burgers now or
protein powders or yeah so there's
something called the biological value
which
um i'll talk about i talk about in my
next book and it talks about
what is bioavailable in your body so a
lot of times people will say
oh i'm going to get 10 grams of protein
from pea protein and get 10 grams of
protein from steak
but the biological value of steak is you
absorb 100 of those amino acids and
they're available to your cells whereas
the biological value of p
protein or plant-based sources is
actually somewhere
averaging between like 60 and 70 so
you would have to eat even more to get
that same amount of protein
in your cells and the way that protein
works is
we use it we ingest it and we use it if
we need it
to make things um so uh
it makes hormones and receptors and it
makes cells
and everything that's in a cell and so
your body's constantly breaking down
cells and rebuilding them but if you're
made of protein
you are right you are a protein being
you're made of protein
uh a low protein diet is going to make
you crave sugar it has
sometimes side effects of feeling
depressed or anxious
so you're going to see that in a diet
where
protein isn't as bioavailable and so for
me
um you know i will start my day
with a smoothie and i do use collagen as
a form of protein because i eat
animal muscle meat right so when you
think about what's in collagen collagen
contains a
uh amino acid called glycine it's a
non-essential meaning your body can make
it but your
body makes like three grams of it a day
to synthesize new collagen in your body
you need about 10 grams a day
so i think collagen protein in say like
a smoothie
or supplementing with it in some form of
a drink is a great way to
up your collagen intake or your glycine
intake to synthesize new collagen
and as long as you're eating other forms
of amino acids
that are easily bioavailable like fish
or
steak or chicken or whatever then that's
a great way to round it out so
as a meat eater i like collagen in my
smoothie i pretty much start my day with
a smoothie
um i would say 90 to 95
of the time um and i love to chew my
food
and that's totally fine like i have
clients who
are like i love your fab four but i'm
having like
a veggie omelet with avocado yeah or i'm
having like your chia flax pudding
so that i can crunch and chew and and
that is it all the same
essentially i mean like does it matter
no is the smoothie somewhat better for
some reason
no and i actually created a smoothie
formula
because what i saw on the market was
that majority of the smoothies are just
full of sugar
or they're really thin and they're not
stretching your stomach so
back to the fab four so you understand
this yeah yeah through all the
categories i want to dive in
yeah so each one of these categories
they all work together to regulate over
eight hunger hormones in your body so
it's not
eight hunger hormones eight hundred
dollars i would say i have 16. yeah
probably well there are more but they're
they're these are the main ones that are
kind of
100 screaming at you to eat like hey
it's time to eat let's eat something i'm
told that's my largest weakness is that
i can't control my hunger
i hate being hungry well
it's not fun you know and so that's
another thing that i work with clients
is like helping them understand
how to actually biologically turn those
hunger hormones off or regulate them
so protein does a really good job of
regulating close to six of those eight
okay then you have fat and you have
essential fatty acids meaning you have
to get your omegas like omega-3 from the
food that you eat
that might be coming from salmon um or
you know
other forms of seafood it's also an
algae if for my vegan and vegetarian
clients i have to
i have them supplement with an algae
supplement but i like to get everything
from food when i can
the algae would be like spirulina or
something no it's actually like an algae
oil oh
so instead of a fish oil pill it's an
algae oil pill because fish eat algae
and that's what makes their
got it that's what makes long chain
omega got it go to the source then
yes so exactly going to the source so
protein and fat are part of the fab four
and fat does a really good job of
releasing satiety hormones so it's
really
that feeling of like this is yummy i
feel calm i feel good it also elongates
your blood sugar curve and slows your
digestion and people like well i want to
digest my food quickly no you want your
food to last for you so that you're not
needing to eat five to six small meals a
day because
the new research actually shows us that
smaller amounts of meals
turning off your hunger and using like a
little
bit of a shorter eating window is better
for longevity it's better
for thyroid health it's better for
digestion
so i'm getting at that if aren't you i'm
not
i'm not actually uh intermittent fasting
is interesting
i do the research is there but what i do
see with a lot of women
is if they're trying not to eat until
let's say 2 p.m
it backfires they binge eat they end up
eating everything in their cabinet
between 2 and 8. it's already dark by 8
o'clock at night
and our insulin sensitivity and our
ability to use our calories as fuel
it's actually higher in the morning it
sinks to a circadian rhythm i was just
gonna ask are you more of a fan of
circadian method
yes absolutely and so when is it solid
at 13 hours or is it more about light
and dark
it's well they're playing the circadian
so yeah circadian rhythm
is the it's the cycle that it's a cycle
of
like being awake and being asleep light
and dark
it's the um every single uh
every single cell in your body has these
little sort of like timers they know if
your body knows
if it's daylight or it's night based on
definitely
wait as soon as i crack and that window
has a little crack of light
i'm like oh thank god i can get up yeah
until then i'm i'm
like i wake up and i'm like oh no but
just have to pee
yeah and i go to the bathroom and i go
back to bed again and then i'm like oh
there's the light and i wake up to the
light
yeah and it's so good to do that because
every single time that you're going
outside or you're getting that light in
your eyes first thing in the morning
your your circadian rhythm is sinking
and your body
your biochemical processes are sinking
to that light cycle
and another way to sink circadian rhythm
is with food so they're finding that
like
these triggers to sink circadian rhythm
include eating so
when people aren't eating until 2 pm and
then eating between 2 and 8
it's it's ok fine you're getting the
benefits of intermittent fasting but is
it backfiring are you overeating
and by the way you're eating when it's
dark at eight o'clock at night i'd much
rather and i tell my clients okay you
want to intermittent fast
get up in the morning work out wait a
few hours to eat
don't wait too long so you binge maybe
you have breakfast at
10 if you wake up at 6 or 9 or ten
and then you're having dinner like five
like my grandma
but don't try to force yourself into
this intermittent fasting thing
if it's not gonna be sustainable for you
and if you have any sort of
emotional eating or you know or do
better eating multiple meals because
intermittent fasting
actually backfires when people don't eat
all day and then they eat a high
so it works the point is is that it will
work i mean if it well
working as in like regulating hormones
as in losing weight
uh yeah calorie restriction is basically
the answer right so i mean if you just
so calorie restriction is interesting
calorie restriction has been proven to
support longevity but calorie
restriction
but intermittent fasting is can be
better than calorie restriction
and that when you are eating in a
specific window
your hunger hormones can go down versus
when you're
calorically restricting throughout the
day those don't actually come
down they just always are like we just
still need more food
we're still hungry yeah you know so it
really depends on the person like
i do we improve
um you know glucose numbers metabolic
numbers on blood tests
um cholesterol numbers we i can improve
um body composition all of that without
having to use intermittent fasting
right so the point is is like it can
work as long as you follow through with
it but the problem is is it's not
sustainable
and it's a high fail rate yeah i'm
always looking at these
i want to call them fad diets or as
tools right so i'm like what is what is
the lifestyle the wellness lifestyle
that you want like you want to eat
healthy and you want to move your body
and you want to sleep well and you want
to manage stress
those should be your pillars okay and
then
then you can be distracted by a tumeric
latte
how you're going to add matcha to
everything how you're intermittent
fasting now yeah
whatever these are all tools don't make
them the basis of how
you're taking care of yourself right
right so the basis of how you're taking
care of yourself
is what does your body physically need
it needs protein it needs fat
it needs fiber right and it needs
phytochemicals and that's from the
greens
so fiber we're talking about those last
two go together
or they can okay so like how do you
separate them
so fiber it it's interesting like people
think about spinach
and they're like oh that's a lot of
fiber not really it's like one to two
grams whereas like you get
so much of it a cup of broccoli you're
getting six grams of fiber
and you need close to 30 grams of fiber
a day
what about like chia seeds so chia seeds
are great and that's
i separate them too because my smoothie
i'm looking for fiber sources like chia
flax
would that fit into fat or would that
fit into fiber chia is a fiber
so when you look at the carbohydrate
content of chia five five so is the
fiber and the fiber is five so then that
carbohydrate is zero
the effect on blood sugar is nothing but
what is it doing it's feeding your gut
microbiome
it's proliferating those cells that
protect you from the outside world with
something like bare like let's say
raspberries or something like
blackberries higher in fiber would that
fit into the fiber category
it would it's also it's it's not my
first choice i'm not looking for like
sugar sources to be the first
source of fiber i like non-starchy
vegetables nuts and seeds
things that are really fiber rich and
then i look at like
the starches whether you're like adding
sweet potato or berries or you want a
tortilla with your tacos and you're
picking like some cool paleo
coconut flour tortilla as sort of like
the not so fab four but like a plus
you you can add it to your plate this is
not about deprivation it is really about
looking for the things your body needs
to turn off your hunger hormones
elongate your blood sugar curve because
the fab four
turn those hunger hormones off slow
digestion so that your blood sugar
doesn't
jack up and crash down that way you're
not coming into lunch starving
and making those bad choices you're
really
you're able to make a healthier choice
not because because you didn't set
yourself up for failure
and then if you're adding those like fun
alternatives let's not make that the
main
main component of your meal because
you're not really getting much
out of that whereas like the berries and
i love berries and i put them in my
in my smoothie but um the formula for
the smoothie
is the fab four and then if you're
adding fruit we're limiting that to a
fourth to half a cup based on like right
how glycemic it is because i don't think
people realize that like a cup of
pineapple is 14 grams of sugar
sure and that's that's actually
something that can kick
people who are pre-diabetic into
diabetic blood sugar numbers wow
so what's your what's your smoothie tell
me what's exactly so every single
morning
i'm either having a collagen protein or
i actually have been using um grass-fed
beef protein lately which has collagen
as well
because it has those branched chain
amino acids that uh
really do a good job making you feel
full and they're great for muscle
building you end up getting 20 to 30
grams of protein yeah i'm always looking
to at least have that minimum of 20
grams of protein
i add about a tablespoon of fat so that
could be
a fourth of an avocado if it's a whole
food fat or like a table
a you know a heaping tablespoon of
almond butter peanut butter
coconut butter cocoa are you a fan of
the oils like
yeah so i like a thicker smoothie and
one of the reasons for that is because
that you have stretch receptors in your
stomach
so if you don't have weight from the
food that you're eating which is another
reason why i created the fab four
smoothie is because all these smoothies
were
pourable they look like almond milk
water i'm like that's not going to
make anyone full so you want to really
stretch those direct receptors
and the fiber and whole food fats do a
better job of doing that
because you think about it it's weight
wait you know um
but yeah i mean i've been known to make
a chocolate olive oil sea salt smoothie
when i felt like i was craving sweet
after maybe you know a super bowl party
and then that monday being like okay i
want to reset
i'm going to throw a lot of greens in
this but i also want it to taste sort of
sweet
how can i how can i satisfy cravings
before they hit
and ease myself like i'm all about that
gradual consistency because what we've
seen in research is consistency
always outpaces it's like these fad
diets and these
these short pushes which bursts of
energy in a workout or bursts of like
changing your life can really motivate
you to clean it up and
keep it clean or at least elevate a
little bit more
like the month or two after but i'm
looking for someone to make something a
lifestyle
right you know that's what it's about so
i'll pick a protein
um i'll pick a most often a whole food
fat but occasionally i'll mess with like
an mct oil or something
um a fiber so chia and flax do a really
good job when
i'm breastfeeding i'll throw some flax
in there i will also throw acacia fiber
in
which is um from the acacia tree
and it's all soluble fiber so soluble
fiber does the best job of feeding that
gut microbiome
and it's just fiber it's really easy
and then um and then the greens is sort
of like big handfuls of spinach kale
whatever
i feel like i could go really green and
i might squeeze a lemon in it
or i might just throw a regular handful
and it might taste like a snickerdoodle
cookie or
a chocolate peanut butter cup so i
know the formula and i teach my clients
the formula i empower them to make their
own smoothies but if
like i said i can think of half a dozen
clients who are like don't make me drink
my breakfast
yeah cool okay then let's critique mine
so normally what i eat is
so i've gone away from bread meat but i
still eat fish
and it has nothing to do with flavor i
absolutely love the taste of
short rib yeah not a problem steak's
delicious but it's more about feeling
sympathy
so i will have
one tablespoon of chia seeds and i'll
put it with hot water and get it on this
like in a in a pan on the stove um heat
it up
because it makes the you know it's like
has the gelatin membrane
around the chia seed that makes it plump
up kind of like a tapioca or exactly
as you know i'm kind of saying it so
people understand what it does yeah and
then
um and it turns into basically an
oatmeal so i put in about
14 adaptogens everything from
ashwagandha
lion's mane cordyceps reishi rhodiola
she legit i mean the list goes on danica
chillin put it all in and then
imagine if i didn't have it and then i
do one scoop of
um i like vega vanilla the vega vanilla
sport
yeah i've tried about a dozen different
proteins and i don't do dairy so any of
the ways are out
i try and stay away from animals so i've
actually had plenty of collagen in my
life and it never bothers my stomach i
do like it
yeah um and but but from the vegan
proteins
that one is to me the least upsetting to
my stomach some of them are kind of
some make my mouth really dry some of
them make me bloated
it's just they're all different like the
brown rice protein to me
is junk like i i really just don't enjoy
it my stomach blows up just like as if i
had gluten
um so uh so i do that and then i put
um somewhere around um
depending on how hungry i'm three to
five ounces of berries or fruit so it
might be like
half of an apple it might be like um you
know again like
actually a small container of
blueberries is six ounces so
and really it's under 20 grams of
carbohydrate so
it's not crazy but i'll put on around
around 15 grams of carbohydrate worth on
top and
that's it that's my breakfast absolutely
delicious there's not much fat in it
no because i found that calories the
calories go through the roof
quickly when you add fat i used to add
almond butter put
nuts on it i mean add chia add flax add
it all
hemp seeds the more the merrier yeah and
then i'm like oh jesus
like all of a sudden you end up 25 grams
of fat which is times nine which is a
lot of calories because there's nine
calories per gram of fat yeah and so
that's how i've like calorically
restricted myself a little bit more
um is just to cut out a lot of added fat
mm-hmm
so that's my breakfast so i like your
breakfast and you're getting a little
bit of fat in your chia seeds yeah
um i think when people pull back on the
fat completely they're not they're
missing out on some satiety
totally you're totally right by the way
yeah you do get hungry like
you need it does help yeah and so you're
just your blood sugar curve you're gonna
go up and crash down a little bit faster
you might be hungry three hours after
that meal versus like four to six hours
after that meal
yeah but if you were a client i would
say
i really like that breakfast i like that
you're adding protein powder you're
really getting that you know the
majority of your hunger hormones calm
i like your adaptogens um there's a good
source of fiber there
um i like the phytochemical content of
the berries
uh probably i would say you know it i
would
prioritize those just for um
just for those benefits phytochemicals
the way that they work in our body which
when i say phytochemicals i mean like
lay term antioxidants
the way that they work in our bodies
body's always trying to get rid of them
so people think oh we're just going to
absorb them they're going to be good for
us but what they do is
a lot of times they cause hormesis where
they like come up to our cell and like
beat ourselves up and our cell gets
stronger it's like taking your
your cells to the gym and it creates gen
you know
uh it turns on genetic pathways that
create like anti-inflammatory enzymes in
our body
so it's a good thing to like look at
each meal and say like do i have
something dark and leafy and green do i
have something like
deep red or purple yeah those are really
that's i'll show you a picture when
we're done with my salad last night you
it's very colorful very very colorful i
love it
right kale purple cabbage you name it
well i think that your your breakfast
sounds actually really really balanced
and it's
um it kind of reminds me of i have this
warm
chia pudding which is sort of the same
thing but i do have
a little bit of flax meal and hem parts
in there but basically
the same idea you know what else i also
love if i'm wanting if i
know that my lunch might be a little
lighter i'm or something like that
if i'm at home it's usually a bigger
meal if i'm out it's usually just like
lettuce and a protein
yeah if i'm at home i'm like oh i can
have really good like more carbohydrate
oriented things that i know fit my
criteria of what i like
yeah so anyway so that might be the
situation and i'll put um
coconut butter like that mana coconut on
it
oh and then you're getting enough fat
that's delicious
and that is like like that's like
nature's frosting
it's so amazing that's exactly how i
would describe it i've actually
thought i've used it before in desserts
i'm like oh i'll just
melt coconut mana and put it on the top
and then like
you make a carrot cake with that on top
it's delicious i feel like my
stomach's probably growling now um
so what is the process so pretend like
we've
we've started the process so pretend i'm
a client okay what happens i'm coming to
you
and let me just make this up so my goal
is to
make sure that my energy levels stay
really good um
i i i just want to lean out a little bit
i'm not looking to make major changes i
just want to feel
energy good energy all the time i don't
want to feel hungry i don't want to be
controlled by that hunger element
and i want to just lean out just a
little bit and i'm okay to do this over
the course of the next like
you know eight to twelve weeks okay
so that would be like the first part of
any consultation was like what are your
goals
what's your timeline um and do you have
metrics like
is it a gene size is it weight is it
measurements um
and you'd be bringing me like any old
blood testing which would be like
anything in the last three to six months
max
oh and if not then we would sold them
get then we would probably get you a
little
we get you an updated blood test so then
what would i what is it a draw
is it a prick is it um both so we can do
a draw
and i work with multiple functional mds
so
a lot of times we're looking for
inflammatory markers like c-reactive
protein and interleukin-6 we're looking
for your metabolic markers like
a1c and glucose and insulin um
we're looking at your cholesterol and
then i might
you know use a glucometer to check your
blood sugar during our meeting and where
you're at
based on like what you're eating and how
is that a prick that's a prick and a lot
of times i'll empower clients to get
their own glucometer and treat
themselves like a diabetic
because it really starts to you start to
understand exactly how
and what foods affect you differently
like it's all going to be based on your
gut microbiome the first
layer of digestion happens you chew your
enzymes it goes into your stomach and
your small intestines and then
though based on your bacterial ecosystem
there's some breakdown that happens
there and the effect
of your blood sugar is going to be
different than the effect on mine from
the same piece of pizza so this is
interesting i listened to a ted talk on
someone that was
like the title of the ted talk is like
what's the perfect diet
and i was like that's what i want to
know yeah so i clicked on it
and the the basically the point was is
that
you react to brown rice different than i
react to brown
you react to ice cream different than me
you react to an apple different than me
yeah and so it really is about
vetting it out yourself so the fact that
you would check your blood sugar to see
like
okay you know what i just had my normal
blackberries in my you know chia pudding
in the morning my you know oatmeal and
my chia oats yeah um you know how does
that affect me and you know today i'll
do it i'll
check it because i did apple i want to
see if apple reacts to me
yeah or like sweet potato that would be
super i should try that
yeah i hate needles but yeah is it the
one where it clicks yeah
it's real it's real easy it's real quick
you don't have to do that it depends on
the client so what we would do then is
go through day in the life of you so
what i'm missing from you
is like what time did you wake up did
you work out because
if you work out before you have that
meal you're gonna have a different
threshold of like what you can
have based on your carbohydrates like
your insulin your muscles would be so
insulin sensitive if you did like a hit
workout or something that
you know dumped your muscles and they're
screaming at you like give us the
carbohydrate sugar give us that i
normally do i always eat breakfast
before i work out
okay i i feel bad in the workout and i
feel
no difference when i do like some people
can't eat before they go work out i love
it
i have to do it i feel no discomfort i'm
not like
sick because of it yeah so i usually eat
i mean honestly it's only like maybe an
hour before i go work out
okay you know and then so i'll work i'll
work out around like 8 30
9 o'clock so eat around like 7 7 30.
um and then i'm i mean i work out from
anywhere from an hour to two hours
and i do everything from hit training to
lifting weights crossfit
like i go intense and pretty intense
and um pretty intense probably really
describes me from a fitness standpoint
yeah um and but every category really is
applicable
um and then so i'm done around you know
10 or 10 or 11 o'clock every day
and then i come home and i'll have kind
of what i would call you know lunch
so around 11 30. i try like hell to get
to noon just to call it lunch but yeah
it's all right
i i would rather have someone shut down
that hunger
and eat eat when they are hungry eat to
like eat to completely shut down those
hunger hormones then do some weird like
i'm waiting till lunch or i'm waiting
till one and i'm gonna have this like
little bite of this or by the time they
get there they're so hungry
that it's and you already know it's
gonna take like 15 to 20 minutes for
everything to sort of register that
you've eaten
so i'd rather you just shut it down when
you feel it so what does one what does
lunch look like
lunch for me like today today it'll be
um
i made some beyond beyond meat burgers
last night okay
um but but otherwise it might be like a
couple of shrimp it might be like
leftover salmon from the night before i
try and get somewhere around
four ounces is not much but um i do
like six probably makes me feel a lot
better but somewhere around
four fives ounces six ounces if i'm
hungry of protein
so today is a beyond meat burger which
has
you know about 20 grams of protein in it
i'm like
17 grams of fat maybe and then i made a
big salad so the salad has kale
purple cabbage parsley peppers
apple cucumber um
tons of tons of vegetables a little bit
of watermelon seeds which are really
high in protein
and not as high in fat per per gram
of protein so yeah this bag was 11 grams
per
um per serving and like hemp seeds would
have been around 14. so they're a little
bit lower in fat than hemp seeds
um and good protein um like maybe 10
grams of protein and maybe four
carbohydrate and two
fiber-ish something like that so there's
some some watermelon seeds in it
um and that's that that's pretty much my
lunch
it's pretty perfect okay yeah olive oil
a little apple cider vinegar
um a little bit of honey okay do like a
little honey in my dressings
um and um lemon
okay so i look at that lunch and i say
okay you do
sort of low glycemic carbohydrates at
breakfast and you do
like the same sort of thing whole food
carbohydrates
it sounds like maybe like your squashes
your sweet potatoes things like that but
you're putting apple in the salad
the only thing that's faster to break
down is going to be that honey
right but you're having it with protein
and you're having it with fat it's going
to smell the digestion of that
i think that that um based on your
workout is not a problem
it would be about if you wanted to lean
out what i'm seeing
is at breakfast you're having a
carbohydrate which means blood sugar
carbs are hitting your bloodstream your
blood sugar is spiking insulin is being
released that's a storage hormone
that lasts in people's body anywhere
between
three and six hours if someone's insulin
resistant it's not you because you work
out the way you do
and you can tell by your figure but like
insulin resistance
if someone has that sometimes insulin is
lasting eight hours after a meal so it's
shutting down fat burning that whole
period of time because you're in
your body is being told to store yeah so
those that spike of insulin at breakfast
you're probably clearing that through
throughout your workout then your
muscles are empty they're excited for
sugar they want to suck that
carbohydrate back in and you're having
it with apple and honey
then i would look at dinner so if you
wanted to lean out and we wanted to have
like the least effect and we wanted to
sort of change your diet
i would make sure that dinner is a
little bit earlier
and maybe five or six o'clock at night
and then you're done eating after that
and i would do a low carbohydrate dinner
because i'd want to have a time period
where you're having
where you're not having that flood of
insulin and you're not having that
chemical messenger that says like
fat cells suck up fat uh muscles suck up
sugar
um because when you're in that storage
mode it's
i think i always say like hormones are
queen like
i've had so many clients come here [ __ ]
which means
which is i've had so many clients sit
down with me and it's like the
quote unquote perfect healthy everything
you'd see is sort of a diet and you look
and it's like
they're having grain free whatever type
of pancake
or oats yeah or fruit and then leo
and then yeah and then at lunch it's
like a big quinoa bowl and
dinner they're like doing some type of
whatever
brown rice or sweet potato on the side
or you like have someone do whole30 and
they
they started their day with fruit and
their end of their day with a whole
bunch of sweet potato and i look at that
and i go okay well you started eating at
6am and if
insulin's not clearing your system for
four to six hours and at lunch you're
doing it again
there's another four to six hours at
dinner you're between you know
five and six pm you're doing it again
then you're really
shutting it down hormonally from when
you wake up until midnight
and so we really only get six hours so
how do i get you an elongated burn
without totally changing your life
right i just pick one of those periods
of time you know what i need to do well
when i type my dinner you'll be like
this is what you need to change
okay so my dinner so i don't i pretty
much i almost i mean like very common be
like
i mean the highest starch would be like
a carrot okay or that's not crazy i
don't even barely eat sweet potatoes at
dinner
um it's uh if i have any sweet potato
it'd be like
at lunch i'll do like sweet potato hash
i kind of do two breakfasts so i do like
shredded i'll do like three
to four ounces of sweet potato and in
the pan it'll be nice and crunchy i'll
do like half of an avocado or a quarter
of an avocado
i use just egg because of all my blood
tests eggs was
registered the highest off the charts of
reaction
for me is that a bad thing no is that
real i can say that right one of the top
eight food allergies yeah and a lot of
people are really surprised to find out
that they have i don't feel bad
but it registers six years apart the
same
different tests six years apart and they
both eggs were off the chair so like
so so i do just egg which is like a mung
bean
um and then i'll do spinach
so if i want to lean it out from a
caloric standpoint then i just take the
avocado out and i just have the sweet
potato
the just egg and the spinach but other
than that dinner is usually just
vegetables so carrot
kale brussels sprouts onion mushrooms
peppers
maybe spaghetti squash that's probably
like the squashy that's probably like
i mean i like white starches like that
yeah like all the squashes i think are a
great way to like pull people back from
those like really starch heavy and then
protein
but where i fail and i know this is the
problem though
um is like last night like any night i
don't
try and keep the calories low which it's
easy to do if you want a dessert to just
say like i'll just have some
strawberries
yeah right so i'll have like some
berries and
i'll either just eat them like that or
i'll put like a little bit of almond
butter on the side
or like last night i made this delicious
little cocoa powder almond butter
a little bit of honey and it was not
very like a fudge bite
it was so delicious and a little bit of
milk to thin it out so i could make it
into like
more of a you know like pudding pudding
yeah
and um and i had some strawberries with
it i mean it sounds
that's my sugar kick of the like the
last thing i eat before i go to bed
would be like some berries
and sugar yeah damn it it's okay
because most people have grown up and
there's these like social
expectations of like oh i'm by myself no
i'm by myself
we're having a dessert but but these are
baked into us like sweet after a meal
like that's pretty
baked in but a good example is i had a
client exactly the same sort of a thing
she was
shooting a movie and craft services was
like bringing out desserts and she was
like just give me the fruit
and so we started bringing out plates of
fruit for her and i and
the quantities were getting a little bit
too big and i don't think she understood
the amount of sugar that was present
there
and so what we did is we actually
switched her to
a dark chocolate bar that used a stevia
erythritol
sweetener in it and that it didn't have
that glycemic effect but she had that
like little bite of
a high phytochemical dark chocolate with
like a little sea salt
yep felt great killed the craving and
she moved on
and then maybe like once a week we'd be
like go have
a blast with craft services enjoy those
strawberries
yeah whatever it is but it's but it also
you know
you calories are important but hormones
i think
really can do a lot more for people in
understanding that hormone
piece because the last thing i want you
would want someone to do
is like continue to lower their caloric
load and always be trying to be at a
caloric deficit to lose weight because
what that i mean what it's doing
potentially
is it's making your body react if you do
it long term like in the short term
uh uh like in like intermittent fasting
or
a bout of caloric restriction can be
beneficial
but if we're doing it for the long term
we can have surges in
you know stress hormones and then also
our body is going to respond it's going
to actually it can start
um it can start lowering our metabolic
rate
and we're going to respond to that and
so our body doesn't work
that's hard and our can't have cells
don't work as hard because they're
getting used to the new normal
of what you've decided is and that's how
yo-yo dieting
sort of you have to keep continuing to
pull back and continuing to pull back so
tools like intermittent fasting or
understanding how to like
bring insulin down or you know
making sure that you're getting good
sleep and you're not over doing caffeine
things that can affect
insulin those all play
a role in helping you hit and maintain
that goal what's your guilty pleasure
then
i'm sure you've been asked that only a
million times and i sound cliche but
no no no i mean i'm like it's funny
because i grew up i grew up here in
southern california where
tacos and guac and chips and like
margaritas and all of that was like a
is a part of my life you know and my
parents were not actually healthy like
my mom
you know i just don't think they had the
information so my mom didn't drink
coffee but she drank
she cracked a can of red coke every
morning before driving me to school
you know so um yeah education is king
it's everything yeah so for me i think
it'd be a tie between some
sort of like snickerdoodle
cookie or like ch
fried chips and guac some mexican yeah
where it's like a fiesta or it's like
i'm stealing santa's
plate of cooking chips guacamoles
margaritas yeah like something
along those lines just um and i i
like to like you i'm looking for ways to
to really enjoy the things i grew up
having with healthier options and i
think if those
if you have those enough and they hit
the spot
then you really aren't craving and
needing to go
get super grindy right right i never
want to be desperate like i never want
to have a photo shoot come up
and not feel like i'm like four weeks
away from
feeling really good about it yeah i mean
like if i have to do a swimsuit or
something like that
i want to know that i'm like a few weeks
away from got it
you know yeah i never want to have to be
like oh got it so i just stopped eating
today then
yeah that's not a good fact it's like
we've cleared we've covered this i can't
the last part i want to know about when
you talk to clients
is if you get into the emotional stuff
if you
get into the more of the emotional
eating the psyche
the relation you know what might be
going on in their relationship or in
their life
because you know that i mean that can be
a driving force but
driving force it's a huge driving force
and
i do we do get into it because it's a
part of the stress piece it's like
tell me about your life tell me about
your relationships tell me about your
relationship with food in the past and
how you've used it
to self sort of like self soothe or self
medicate and there have been times where
my suggestion to the client is not about
controlling the food more
it's about like maybe trying therapy or
maybe trying breath work or maybe trying
meditation and it is not where i'm like
hey just go download this
app but i do make those suggestions for
someone who
would like to use that i have
practitioners here in la that
i refer out to if i think someone needs
body work or they need to try breath
work
or and sometimes
sometimes it's above my pay grade and
sometimes i have to
say like we need to work this out first
because
and i will only know that if i've worked
with you for four to six weeks and i've
seen it
kind of crop up like an emotional scar
crop up and
really get in your way of eating clean
it's like we gotta move through that
emotion
and if you're stuffing food you're
blocking that emotion from moving
through you
yeah and we and it's really painful but
we have to face it
head-on because it's in the silence
where we want to just eat to satisfy
that
whole or fill the void and
so many of us have used that i think
about like back in college when i was
studying for
finals or you know everyone was like
eating to study
to stay awake to you know and it was
like sugar-based things
it's adderall yeah
seriously but um yeah it's a it's a hard
piece of the puzzle because it's so
intertwined food is so emotional
and my goal was always to build a system
or build a program that allowed people
to take ownership
over what they were eating to really
love what they were eating to have the
flexibility to like go to a dinner with
friends and not feel like they couldn't
celebrate life
and allow for food to be
love and emotion without it causing a
trigger point for someone
to go binge because they broke their
diet well i feel like
you know you operate from this place out
of love not fear like you have
you know developed like the methodology
to being a very positive association
with it so
like where did you get that mindset
where you
connected more with the positive and you
have that positivity like you're a
positive person
so are you yeah i try i mean but it's
effort but
um you know there has to be there are
sometimes there are stories or
transition points or
you know somewhere some point in time
where it clicked for you where you're
like
oh man i can't do this anymore did you
ever have that or has that just been
like ingrained in you like was it a
childhood thing or did you
do you have a story um i feel like i've
i
there's a little bit of an innate like
glass half full
optimism optimistic person inside of me
um and what what i started to find
when i look back i'll just get like
super vulnerable when i look back
and i went to college and i had sort of
always loved health and nutrition and
would read these diet books and played
soccer and was a captain of
my soccer team in asb super involved
like
loved my friends um didn't really have a
serious boyfriend until college but i
like would go to the dances and have fun
and had a lot of confidence
and i would read the diet books for the
science
and i would maybe do them just to try
them out for a couple of days it never
lasted long term
but it never made me feel bad about
myself when it wouldn't work
but then i dated someone who
uh being a serial monogamous my parents
had been married for over 40 years like
i was being cheated on without knowing
it he's you know an
athlete a good-looking guy um and it was
the first time my confidence took a real
hit and so i started to read these diet
books
and sort of really it manifested in me
like needing to change my body
right i must not be pretty pretty enough
skinny enough
good enough yeah which is the first time
i ever felt that way yeah
and so i started to read these diet
books and then i really started to do it
and then when it would fail because
ultimately like i'm a college kid eating
in college cafeteria
or i'm out with friends and i'm wanting
to like really celebrate life and be
this positive person i had always been
my confidence took major hits and i'd be
like oh i need to
and what i felt was like i talk about
the pendulum ball
and you said like balance doesn't exist
it's like this thing where people think
they're going to be perfect and their
ball is going to stop
and it's not like it's always going to
be bouncing it's like
homeostasis it's even your blood sugar
is going up and down and up and down and
up and down always it's con it's never
just solid like steady state and that's
how we are emotionally too and so i'm
thinking about this like light flow and
what ended up happening was
i was like doing these diets trying to
do them and then i was swinging back to
like
going to cabo and spring break with all
my friends and
yeah and feeling out of control and not
to the point where i'm like oh i'm binge
drinking but i was
where i was like eating all the chips
and guac you know and
feeling worse about myself and so what i
was finding i was like
all of these diets do are make you feel
like junk
about yourself and your body and it was
killing my confidence
to do the regular things that i would do
like
you know be in a a role in my
sorority or like play on my soccer team
or be with my friends and
how is food affecting my confidence in
this way
like how i can control all of my life
but i can't control
my food choices i'm i can't not eat that
chocolate i can't not
why why is this so you know well one
it's like human nature to eat
and it also is also necessary it's
necessary it's our first coping
mechanism
but the more i tried to control it the
more my pendulum ball went like this
well because it's a polarity right so
total player
or you're over here on the restriction
side the more you usually fall into the
the binge side of things and so if you
can just
stay closer to the middle it doesn't
swing so far
and you feel more comfortable in control
which is what
it just feels like you know so authentic
to you that your
you know your program revolves around
this
sustainability um and
ability to control those triggers yeah
you know and
and it's what i needed it's really what
i needed i need it
and so i stopped going to try to do
other people's things and i started
looking at these books differently um
you know i got out of that bad
relationship i turned back
you know i really came back to myself
gave you the confidence i mean
it's kind of a side question but i you
know a lot of the things that that i
like asking people about on the show
or just certain things that they've
experienced that are emotional that help
them transition
like you were in this yo-yo of
lacking confidence and then trying to
get confidence in these other ways to
you know impress somebody and you know
eventually
you left and so what gave you that kind
of confidence
well it's interesting it sort of would
have to we'd have to go
into the layers but um you know
i was raised in a family where the
person that you're with
physically emotionally and sexually is
the person that you marry and so
being that that relationship was my
first real relationship and something
i felt like this innate need to hold on
to it and to make it work
and honestly i just hit rock bottom it
was like embarrassing
when i would find out that this was
happening it's nothing that i would ever
stand for for my friends yeah like i
didn't understand who i was i didn't
feel anywhere near
close to myself because if it was my
friend i would have been like what the
hell are you doing isn't that
interesting
yeah and like but for some reason you're
like oh i'm gonna like
say it out loud and they're like what
would my oh my friend would say leave
[ __ ] yeah
everyone would say leave you know and it
it just got embarrassing enough
and um and to the point where i
i was yeah i was done and i needed to
move on and
i think people just hit rock bottom and
something like that and based on
you know i am thankful for the
confidence that my parents instilled in
me at a young age and that sports
instilled in me and like
my friends because i think that timeline
was shorter than
because of those factors and i feel bad
when people don't have
a little bit of that foundation wherever
they get it to be able to
to look at someone who's not treating
you right and say i'm out
and i deserve better and that's sort of
you know i just hit that breaking point
and was like you know what
i might disappoint my parents for not
you know being with this person that i
was
with for the first time and marrying
that person but this person isn't right
for me and it's not what they want for
me anyways
and i'm gonna own that and go back to
being myself and taking care of myself
first and then we'll
i'll you know see who i meet and your
perception on the situation was of
course that was who you're supposed to
spend forever with and i bet your family
was probably pretty happy it was going
after you yeah oh my gosh there so it's
really hard that went up in smoke
yeah getting in your own head and that's
can be a problem too where we just
live by these subconscious you know
paradigms that have been established for
us that they're really ours
they're not real they're just in our
head totally and it's really
who you are and like really getting to
know yourself not who you
you were raised to be understanding who
you were raised to be or or what
expectations
you know a lot of my parents
expectations were things that really
helped me to excel in my life
right and really rounded out who i am as
a person
but there are certain you know i think
about that with my son now i'm like oh
gosh like i don't want to
create i want to create expectations for
him that allow him to excel
but i want him to have the freedom to
create and be anyone he wants to be
without what what are the most important
like what are the things that you've
held on to that you're like these values
are are values that i never want to let
go of and then what are maybe a couple
that you've
come away with as you've grown up to go
look i didn't realize how important
this was yeah um i would say
that my parents instilled a really
strong work ethic in me so it was never
about applauding the a
it was applauding the effort so my dad
always
asked us when we got our grades or when
we played a game
or when we were with our friends
like did we show up like did you try
your best
because it wasn't did you score the goal
were you the best person on the team did
you get straight a's
because that was a rewarding the end
goal and
what it he did instead and what my
parents did instead was they rewarded
the effort
and so i was never afraid to do anything
different because i knew with enough
effort
i would get there because i knew how to
hustle i knew how to drive i knew how to
put my head down and do the work
and so i wasn't afraid to try something
new
and i think that is so important for
kids nowadays is
we're applauding things that they're
good at so
maybe you know they're good at a certain
sport or they're good at expert in class
and then they end up feeling safe in
that
and creating a career in that without
even asking themselves do they
like this so i really loved that i think
my parents did a good job when it comes
to that i think
um i think some of
the social expectations uh
it's sort of a catch-22 because i really
do love that
i wasn't so i wasn't really boy crazy
and i really was about me which i think
our younger generation
is doing a really good job of in junior
high in high school now
and i really hope that that continues to
be something that
young women really focus on is who they
want to be the career they want to build
like you're right like i really
positivity deposits
right now like i really like the
positivity of the positivity is coming
out right now yeah like i love that
um but there are some expectations that
i think
uh will make people feel shame
and so i'd like to leave some of
some of those expectations those social
expectations to my child like just
really a lot
have an open conversation with them
about what it means to be human
and perhaps in a religious household
shame is such a common word with people
with religion
yeah and it is you know i'm
traditional catholic uh i grew up in a
catholic family so there's always this
the layer of like forgiveness right and
um always being able to be forgiven um
but
in a lot of religions you look at like
wars
and expectation and shame and
you know there's a lot of that where i'm
you know i'm really about the person
and whatever whatever they want for
their life whatever their truth
is and so i don't really
i don't really relate to some of those
expectations
because i don't think people need to
feel shame for being who they are
and having life experiences
um what i what i do love about it
is that you know when it it when it is
a good place for people where it is a
good place for people to like have
community
or to support people
in their community but i don't you know
it's a heart it's a hard line it's hard
it's not a hard line on this side it's a
hard line for those and those that have
the line
yeah exactly exactly that's that's the
thing is that
anything that anything that um draws
lines in the sand and
has like rules i mean you know there's
no gray
right i mean it's like black and white
there's no gray and there yeah life is
all gray
yeah it's just it's just it's all shades
of ombre
and people need to be okay with that
yeah yeah so i would say
i'm ombre whereas like generations
before me were very black and white
yeah how do you want to raise your son i
want him
i really just want him to be happy with
who he is i want him to get to know
himself i want him to be excited
and thankful and really grateful to live
every single day i think
we are blessed in a way where he with
hustle with drive with effort like
he really can be whatever he wants and
he's a healthy young
little boy who sky is the limit and i
want him to feel that be grateful for
that and give back for that
so i'm sure you're going to do a great
job
you're a very positive person very
i have a lot of really good ideals and
mindsets
and goals and visions and just
you know i think that positivity is
and truth right truth truth vibrates at
a very high frequency
so i think you're going to raise a
wonderful wonderful boy into a man
thank you hopefully a very vulnerable
one yeah that's that's
right i mean i think that you know the
paradigm is shifting in that in
in the world of men and women and
masculine and masculinity and femininity
and
you know i was just talking to louis
house about that he wrote the book
masking mask
of masculinity and you know i do think
that paradigm shift is happening and so
you know culture is coming around and
it's going to be acceptable to
live and speak and you know be in your
truth
which is always the most always the best
place to be
totally thank you it was a pleasure
thanks for having me
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you